You are listening to radiolab radiolab
from
W. N. Y. S. T. E. N. N. P. R.
You don't take it down at one
base of bed? No, this is fine.
What are we doing about the
podcast, by the way? Oh, do you?
Should we do that now? Yup. Hey,
I'm Jabil. Rod. This is radio lab.
Yes, we, yes it is. No, we're doing
the introduction. Ready? Here we go.
Let's do it for real.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab podcast
and today on the podcast we want to tell
you about a guy who hears music in a way
that is just extraordinary and painful.
Just thinking about this story makes
my head hurt. That's Jessica Banco.
She's a reporter and she's the one
who initially told me the story
a little while ago. I
went up to visit this guy,
Bob. Nice to see
excuse my feet here.
And he lives in a tiny town in
Michigan with his wife Linda.
And who is he? He's an
amazing piano player.
The Library of Congress actually
called him a national treasure. Really?
He's had this special relationship
with music ever since. He was a boy.
Did you grow up with any other instruments
inside the house other than the piano
or was that what you started out? Well,
I am, my mother made me take
piano lessons and I hated it.
I didn't like the sound of minor keys
and the piano teachers had me playing a
recital in which there's a
Schubert minor. He piece in it.
So on the recital I played it in major
[inaudible]
and everyone thought that was a travesty.
These days though, his mean music isn't
so much Schubert. It's actually ragtime,
one three, four, one, two,
three, five the rhythms.
So the thing about ragtime
is that oftentimes the player
is actually playing two
different rhythms at the same
time. One with the left hand,
one with the right hand, right.
Then you put the rhythms
of three in there, right?
No.
The thing about Bob is he can
do this like times a thousand.
What does that even mean?
Well, let me back up.
I first heard about Bob from a
neurologist named Kirsten Betterman,
Kristen Betterman, who's now at Penn State
University. First time I heard about,
but Milan was who friends first and heard
about Bob from a colleague who'd seen
him play for an audience, so
I might just take a tune like
he was actually playing multiple
rhythms with his two different hands and
switching back and forth between different
pieces of music and carrying on a
conversation so you
should at the same time,
well let's say it's not true.
You can look up videos of Bob on youtube
and you can see him performing and
throwing out jokes,
but at times you'll see him carry on a
full conversation while playing from the
perspective of a neurologist.
This is actually really hard because
the part of your brain that should be
engaged in playing a piece of music that
complicated should also be engaged in
having a conversation. The talking part
and the playing part of the same part,
the same part in most of us for
most people, that sort of thing.
Playing a complex piece of
music and having a conversation
would would interfere
with one another. Yes. That's
what you usually would think.
Unless you're highly skilled and you
play maybe one piece of music at a time
that you've done multiple times,
but even then it would be
very difficult to this degree.
So Kirsten got in touch with Bob and she
started asking him some questions about
the way you would perceive music and how
in the course of chatting with him and
talking about how he perceives music and
all of this, he happened to say to her,
but I could hear, uh,
an entire symphony in my hand and I didn't
think that was too big a deal cause I
always listened to two of them at once.
He told her I only have to focus on the
one mentally that I want to hear at a
given time. And then that's a piece
I play. But I hear them all ongoing.
Did he just say he can hear two different
symphonies in his head at the same
time? We thought this
was very unusual. Yeah.
But I mean are we talking the full
symphonies or just the melodies?
Every instrument. Every
instrument. And he can focus in and
turn one of them up, one of them down
and they both run the same old tediously.
Huh. So then, um,
she pushed to the envelope and
asked me if I can, I hear three,
three pieces of music as well.
I don't know. Never tried. Yeah.
But he was like, yeah, I
think I could do three.
When we challenged them a
little bit, actually you said,
I can't do four if you asked me, but I
wouldn't go any further than that. Nope.
That's total just for
symphonies at the same time.
[inaudible]
that's just nothing but, but noise.
Absolute cacophony. You know, the,
the four pieces of music that just,
wow. I said nobody can do this.
[inaudible] was really critical.
Yeah. Cause it's not true.
We had to think about how to test this.
Let me tell you about how the experiment
worked and then tell me if you think
it's true. All right.
We came up with the behavioral test and
so the first thing Kirsten had to do was
find to control someone to compare Bob
to, right. So she found a conductor,
Peter Perri, who was the former
conductor of the Winston Salem symphony,
who is himself an accomplished musician.
Before the test, she sent him in Bob,
four pieces of music. We had
a Schubert's and funny, yeah,
we have rounds. Yeah.
Two
[inaudible]
and finally one from Mendelson
[inaudible].
So you have to keep in mind these four
symphonies are in different keys and
different tempos, very different.
And the themes and instrumentations.
And the challenge for them was to
learn these before pieces of music.
Completely memorize them
for different tunes.
And they only gave me a couple of days
to listen to them and then play them in
their mind.
And we would then ask them where in a
restorative piece they would be after an
arbitrary time. I'm not really
following. Okay, so here's what they did.
They put these guys in the
scanner and they said to them,
I want you to play the music in your
mind. Play the music in your mind,
close your eyes and imagine the music.
So no music is playing out loud,
no music playing just inside
their head. Are they imagining it?
However they want or know exactly
what they had heard on the CD.
So same as is coming in
and out. Yep. Same Tempo.
So if it was a Vivace on the CD
Vivace in their head. Exactly.
And why were they doing this again? Well,
they wanted to see if these
guys could track via memory,
these really complicated pieces of music.
So they put the guys in the scanner,
they're laying there and on
a screen in front of them,
the word start flashes and at that moment
they start playing the first piece of
music back in their head.
[inaudible]
in the control room. They're tracking the
music themselves to follow the timing.
The researchers, yeah. Oh, so while
Bob and the student are imagining it,
they're actually keeping track
of where the real CD is. Exactly.
[inaudible]
they let it go for awhile.
and at an arbitrary moment they
say stop and then they say,
sing to me exactly where you are in the
music. Like the note, the exact phrase,
they go back, they compare
the timing to the CD, right.
To find out if these guys can
really recreate inside their heads.
Exactly what they'd heard. And um,
so I will conduct our control or is able
to listen to one piece of music at a
time and wants to really ride on
target with the right answer on.
Timing was in a second. Boom.
So this conductors imagined symphony
was only a second off from the real one.
Yup. Same with Bob. So Bob's within
a Notre too bad now. Round two,
the multisite on task, as we called it,
they told them both to start
that first piece of music again.
[inaudible]
and then a little bit later they
said start the second piece of music
in your head
simultaneous
[inaudible] [inaudible]
all right. I've already
like, come on. It's crazy.
Like this is wishlist slipped in the
fantasy and that's what happened for the
conductor. He couldn't do it. He
couldn't do two simultaneously. Yeah,
of course. Couldn't do
it. It's impossible.
Almost little chance. He said this
is an overwhelming impossible task.
His brain just shut down.
Well, like he died or something.
He stopped even being able to
track the first piece of music. Ah,
he just got confused now where Yoda, Bob,
they put me into the MRI and the, they
asked me stare tune one in your head.
So I did.
[inaudible]
then roughly 10, 15 seconds later,
I got a message on the screen.
It said continue
listening to one start two
and then 15 seconds later
continued listening to tunes
one and two starts three
[inaudible] the same thing is true for
[inaudible] [inaudible]
then on the screen it's in Stanhope
and then Kirsten came in a little, um,
I could hear her talking to me
from somewhere and she says, Bam,
tell us where are you?
Where are you in tune one fatal
right now? What do you hear?
So I told her and um, I
didn't, I described, um,
what the piece was playing at that point.
Does that Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
And the same thing with tuna,
three and four.
She announced that I was exactly
right into the note in each one of the
symphonies,
Jess
telling me something that's
just not really, you know,
I've got a lot of intentions. Just
my common sense right now is yelling,
three-year-old. It really, it really
is mind boggling to think about. Mixed.
My brain hurt. But you know, we
proved to you. Yeah, you can do it.
When Kirsten gave you the different
pieces of music to listen to,
Huh?
Did any of them clash? [inaudible]
no.
No. They don't clash it. They're
all just playing different pieces.
There's nothing chaotic about it.
All right. So assuming this is true,
how does he do this? How does he
explain to himself how he does this?
So I think there's two things going on
here. The first has to do with emotion,
emotion,
FAPAs using different brain
areas. I think in his case,
probably more more emotional brain center.
Yeah. Motion deepens the way that we
experience things, make stronger memories.
And Bob has a really strong emotional
relationship with music. With the wheel.
Yeah. But it's a little bit beyond
the whole minor keys make me feel sad.
He has really specific emotions associated
with individual keys on the scale.
Huh? I'm gonna when I hear
c major, it's a very bland,
he is like, um, I don't
know how to describe,
it's like heating water, super,
something like that. But d major,
the break he,
that makes me want to dance even
though I can dance and every he ever,
every one of the keys of the piano had
a different emotional attachment to me.
So for Bob, if just the keys are
triggering different emotions. Yeah.
Imagine what it must be like
when you get to actual music.
[inaudible]
so you think that's something about how
he experiences the emotions of the music
makes it etch more deeply in his brain
or something? Yeah, I think he's,
when he's got these four
pieces of music going,
he's not thinking hard about
tracking each one of them.
He's already in them.
He feels them inside his body and you
can feel more with them one feeling at a
time. So that's one idea.
The second idea has to do actually more
with image and space really listened to
the two different pieces. So Bob often
closes his eyes when he's talking.
You don't hear. It just helps him focus.
So I asked him if he could try playing
back two pieces of music right now.
And I asked him, when you hear
these two symphonies in your head,
what are you seeing?
I can picture, um,
two symphony orchestra
sitting side by side.
He actually sees the literal
orchestras in his head.
Yeah. And I see them as silhouettes.
There's no conductor
in front of either one.
There's a brownish hue
out in front of them.
Like it's just a floor that's more the
color of the deep brown of a Valium and
in back of them. And there's a
semi-circle. It's bluish in color.
Then when I listen to them,
I'm going to listen to Brahms second
symphony over in the left side,
[inaudible]
and uh, over in the, uh,
right side. Don't turn in.
The emperor can share the
third movement of NATO.
And so I'm listening to that. No,
these are in two different keys.
Emperors and e flat. Brahms is d.
So now if I want to pay
particular attention, oh,
let's say I'm going to
listen to the emperor here.
I'm going to go into the major. I
just sped it up. Yeah, I can. I can.
They can speed the thing out and
they'd go to some of their part in it.
I can jump backwards. Let's see,
just a minute. I can hear it. An F,
I can put it into any here. One,
two but I'm going to rar forward in this
third movement of the emperor here and
I'm listening to the a e major variation
on the piano, which is just like a,
or it's just racking and this
a beautiful, he made your part
pivoting around to the Flint and going
up and down from there and the piano.
Wow. Wow.
So his crazy towns may have something to
do with this movie making thing that he
does in his head. Yeah, but it's not
just a movie. It's like a three d movie.
He can use it to find out where a
specific instrument is. How do you mean?
In his mind's eye,
he can fly out over these orchestras
and actually look down on the individual
instrument he wants to see.
When I'm looking down and I see
the piano out in front of them,
he can zoom in and see them
playing their instrument.
Okay,
now I'm up there in the air listening
to this thing over and over on my left
side. They can still hear this
brown is going along at Brahms.
I can only see the
silhouettes from the front,
whereas the gathering
of the emperor for here,
I can see full color and every person's
face in it and plus here the lines that
they're playing
and as he's flying out
over these orchestras,
the instruments actually get louder
and softer depending on where he is.
Like if he goes behind
orchestra number one,
I can hear the bass, which can much
louder than let's see and yeah.
Then if I go over to the left
side, I'm hearing the violins
and he says he can float right above
the players and actually see [inaudible]
what they're doing. They can
see every raincoat in the,
in the pleaded shirts of their tech CEOs
[inaudible]
and they can see the deep brownish
orange color of the violas.
And I can hear the deep sound,
beautiful sound of that low viola
[inaudible]
and I can hear every little Rhett
Rosin scratch a cross their bows
[inaudible]
God listening to music for this guy
must be like, like an acid trip.
The way that he's describing
it, I think it is.
And when he listens to recorded music,
it's so much diminished from what he
feels when he's imagining it. Huh.
So he doesn't listen to cds. He cannot
stand listening to cds Dow. Wow. Yeah.
He's a real example of the
extremes of the human mind.
So what does he do with these crazy
towns? I mean, is he a, is he like a,
a, a billionaire? Nope. First of all,
ragtime is not exactly the most popular
form of music in the United States at
this point. Um, but it's what he
likes to play and he plays, you know,
250 shows a year.
But a lot of them are at
stark societies or churches.
Oh, Linda and I, we've had a small
motor home. It's an airport bus,
one of those little 15 passenger buses.
It's got a hot shower and a
bathroom and I'm bad too of course.
So you know,
he travels around and his little motor
home with his wife when he can and
without her when he can't and sleeps in
Walmart parking lots is working on an
opera, which is mostly done.
And he writes it in his head while
he's driving and then he sits down in a
McDonald's and writes it out
on paper. And uh, you know,
that's pretty much what he does with this
[inaudible]
thanks to reporter Jess
Banco for that great story.
And also to producer Mark Phillips
for making it sound so good.
But why should we share the
information that we just did?
Why not do the outro in a way that Bob
Millman fully and completely appreciate
you mean?
So we should say it all together in a
big simultaneously he'll be able to think
the Jed side and then the
Roberts. Okay. Ready? Yep.
You play the piano or listeners that are
piano players from our label composure,
Walmart, worst parts of those pianos.
They get a Walmart right into
discounting things today.
The left hand hitting the piano. Did I
see that.